i've made guys like eat dog food before
like toilet bowls
um drink toilet water
[Music]
we brought together seven sex workers
i'm a sex worker
i'm a sex worker and i'm an only fan sex
worker i'm a cam girl
i'm a sex worker i am a sex worker i'm a
sex worker
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll win a cash prize if the liar
survives they win the cash prize
this is odd man out
my game plan going into this is to keep
it really casual i don't want them to
think i'm too researched
you know to rehearse i'm not going to
say much if you talk too much people get
suspicious
i feel like in this industry we have to
talk about a lot of
taboo things that not a lot of people
talk about and i think it might be
pretty easy to pick up on somebody who
hasn't
had those conversations before i'm kind
of
looking for someone to not know a sex
worker slang
feeling pretty nervous about this
because i'm kind of outing myself here
and try not to be too quiet i just hope
that they don't think it's me
i have a sixth sense for bs so
i think i'll be able to figure it out
i plan to not really attack people
because i've seen how that ends up on
the game or like being too
what's the word eager i'm really shaky
right now
stage fright love to see it oh my god i
am not a good liar
i don't know how i'm gonna do
[Music]
okay
okay so we're starting off to say hi hi
okay i'm gonna ask the first question i
think like yes i wonder who's gonna ask
the first question because like
it's not gonna be me what kind of sex
work
sex work is a really huge umbrella term
so
i want to know what everyone does are
they dancers are they full service are
they a cam girl like let's see what's up
um okay so jessica's a cam girl she
definitely kind of looks like a camera
because like her background loves
our cam girls oh my gosh
twitter oh so much is happening
yes we love to annihilate
little pathetic [ __ ] boys a lot of
girls seem to be online
which means that anybody could be lying
but do you know do y'all's families know
um
oh jessica just asked where we're from
whoa
she just asked us where we're from which
is really important because like
as a sex worker you don't want to have
like your name or like your location
oh i'm asian so my
parents literally can't
parents don't know yet oh my gosh
they're gonna know now uh
and i tried it but everyone kind of goes
to me
oh seeking arrangements you yikes
there's lots of different types of sex
work going on here
they are trash on sticky now i'm trying
to scroll up to see what maya does
what do you mean you're a host at a club
my parents know that i do social media
marketing
she's been dancing since she's 19. none
of these people could be sex workers
honestly
because like okay see she has like two
jobs that makes sense
i'm so bad at typing like do you do it
because you have to
i honestly
did it because i need it side jobs are
the best
for taxes what does that mean i don't
know
maya that's suspicious this is like so
[ __ ] confusing
this is so so confusing oh my god
college is expensive do you write off
beauty on taxes
yes okay anna knows and what are you
studying i'm in college i'm not in
college i don't give a good about
college let's talk
about those taxes because that's a
pretty good question
oh that's jessica who i was suspicious
of
all right you guys have 30 more seconds
oh my gosh 30 seconds this is my first
year in only 10 so i don't do taxes
that is suspicious you should do taxes
maybe because they just started and it's
not next year
i don't know who it is because
everyone's being just like super cute
i'm gonna go with that with jessica yes
oh my god we should all be friends on
twitter
all right and that's time oh my gosh
everything went so
fast people are asking questions
answering questions
gonna vote for maya because i feel like
she may have stuck out to other people
so i won't be alone on my vote and then
also i just feel like she was
like all over the place and what she was
saying i actually really like everyone
so far
i don't want to pick someone i think i'm
going to pick maya
just because she was kind of off i don't
know claire didn't really say much
i still feel like it's clear i felt like
jessica
is the mole because at first she asked
about where we live
i think that's super weird that she
would ask us that um i think most sex
workers know that our location is
super important to keep private i think
i'm most suspicious of claire
i don't know why not much to go off
there was a lot going on
i'm gonna vote for claire because she
just didn't give me enough
i was looking for more it's hard being
the mole because you just have to pick
out the innocent ones
to save yourself claire didn't talk much
the first
person voted out is claire
i can't believe i got eliminated already
the first round
maybe i did answer enough questions or
ask enough questions
okay hello hi guys
it's so like cool to see everyone
because i was like trying to look at the
little pictures
and now i can see everyone else i'm
gonna subscribe to everyone's like
page whenever this is over hell yeah so
does everyone have an only fans
okay wait does everyone have only fans
yeah that's nice
yeah like everyone in the world you just
have to because
you know it's popping off right now you
need to get that back
i see you got the gamer chair i see the
gamer chair and i see the headphones
you are for sure a cam girl
i mean it is just comfortable and you
have the voice you have the voice
yeah are you guys on like any other
platforms like do you guys use like
twitter
do you guys have like a clip store do
you guys have like twitter instagram
cb like thought about using twitter but
i just haven't yet so i just do it
through my instagram
you gotta twitter is like the hub of the
sexpert community that's where i've met
all of my friends and you never
worry about it for me i personally had
to start a new twitter and a new
instagram just because the shame like
not the shame but just me personally
yeah i live in a small town the shadow
band
is real yeah i know on instagram
instagram hates sex workers oh i know
you can have like 40 followers
just doing your own [ __ ] and then so if
you like if you deleted your pages how
did you like build your following back
up
to like and they will you know get
people to subscribe and stuff
i haven't ever had my page ban banned i
haven't either
no i haven't either thank god because
like susie did right
you got yourself i haven't i haven't
planned my i haven't had my page banned
i was catfished by someone else on
seeking arrangements
oh okay that was the thing and that's
where that ended y'all like no more
like it was scary it was scary so wait
is everyone here like a cam girl then
that's what everyone does except for
maya my guest maya you dance
yeah i danced and i just started free
fans just because the pandemic
like shut my club down so yeah and then
everyone else is like um just like cam
and just online stuff then right only
family
i don't do camming but i haven't only
vans why did y'all
start your only fans i guess we kind of
went over this but now we can talk about
it instead of oh yeah
i started mine last september i started
a year ago just because my friends
that i was already doing sex work for a
year and doing like clips and camping
and then
only fans started to really pop off and
so it was just a good place to get like
all my fans in one place
i started camping like a few months ago
just to like because it was fun
what sites do you cam i used
and i literally only did it one time
that's all you have to do they have like
bots that will record
right um so i started doing it about
five years ago i started just doing like
little things like um
good money uh yes
for so long you gotta be making money
i started five years ago too when i was
18. ooh
veteran okay yes yes i started when i
was 19.
um i started doing things like that one
website extra lunch money i don't know
if it's still around
yeah yeah they did like a lot of fem dom
stuff on there too when i was like wait
i like this way more than like doing all
the others
being a dom is life changing like i have
literally like i am so much confident so
happy with myself now that i've done i'm
just like
[ __ ] you boys yes exactly
like that small penis humiliation
i love it i love it have any of you guys
worked at a
cam studio no no no no no no
you're gonna be like you have yes i was
gonna ask like how much is
yeah the don't do it it's just they take
don't do that that's why i was like in
shock i was like whoa and don't do that
yeah
no oh that's right yeah no i tried it
i've heard they take a big chunk of your
money
i had no clue cam studios existed hey
and only fans is already taking enough
of our money like
can we all just like percent come on
twenty percent what are
what are your subscription rates five
dollars
mine's fifteen fourteen ninety mine's
always on sale you know for like five
dollars but my normal price is how you
get this
sending out yeah private messages and
then you get that bag
okay so that round was super
overwhelming
like i'm usually like a really talkative
person but like
those girls were like ah i feel like i
was invisible and i was really trying to
get my questions in but no one would
answer them maya knew
about cam studios but also she
said that only fans takes 30 of your
money
and only fans takes 20 of your money i
can't ignore my gut
yeah okay i voted for bunny i feel so
bad but like i don't know she just i
don't know
i want to vote for susie right because
like
right now maya's got me convinced enough
to keep her so i'm gonna do
susie just because i'm going to vote for
coxy just because
she wasn't talking a lot and i know i
wasn't talking a lot either
i am going to go with bunny honey you
weren't talking enough girl
it's different when they see you it
really is i have to go with maya
i'm sorry maya you're so sweet and i
definitely want to go to the clubs with
you one day
there is a three-way tie
the tie is between susie maya
and bunny i'm going to give susie maya
and bunny each 30 seconds individually
to make a case for themselves and then
we're going to re-vote
okay so i've been dancing since i was
19.
um i started because i'm in college for
pre-law and i wanted to make extra bank
then i started cam growing around 20
didn't really like it too much because i
wasn't making a lot of money
recently because of the pandemic i
started only fans just because i
couldn't work at the strip club anymore
and i tried arizona
so yeah um and my only friend's
subscription is
10.99 a month my way to get
subscribers is by doing my little videos
okay so i've been um doing sex work
since i was 18.
um i originally started with like a
premium snapchat
and i did that for i guess four years up
until last november
um like i said i did cam one time i did
on chatterbait the whole thing got
leaked
and yeah i started my only fans last
november i was in a group with a whole
bunch of girls
and then um i got out of that group i
made my own group now i've been coaching
girls
um i don't do the whole referral thing
because that's a scam
hi everyone my name is susie uh i
started sex work when i was 18
like i said on seeking arrangements that
went really well for a while uh i did
lots of you know um going out on dates
with them
and then lots of
you know just like meeting up at their
hotels and
doing some stuff for them that i didn't
quite feel comfortable doing
anymore especially after i got catfished
and then last july i started
college and i needed to make some side
money
and since i didn't want to go back to in
contact meeting with people i decided to
do only fans so i'm my own damn boss
and the next person who has been
eliminated
so i think i got eliminated this round
just because i didn't talk enough
i want to give other people the space to
talk i didn't want to talk over anyone
so i think people thought that maybe i
was waiting on other people to speak
first
okay i have a question what is your guys
favorite part of sexer
i was going to say it depends on what
kind of sex work you're asking me
but for me just doing only fans
and being your own boss setting your own
hours your own flexibility
especially for me if insecurity was
something that you grew up with
and then you know overcoming that and
then have people you know
pay you to see you know parts of your
body it's like whoa
you know it's totally it's like i felt
insecure about my body type
until i started sex work and i really
embraced it
and because people want to see your body
and appreciate you
my favorite part is just talking like to
get literally paid to like
look hot and talk like nothing better
like i can i could talk your ear
it's given me a lot of confidence like
low-key i used to think like my private
area was the ugliest thing in the world
and now i'm just like you know what
literally i like hated it i was like so
instituted but then once i started
shipping and only fans i just was kind
of like wow people actually think i'm
beautiful
like i'm getting this money and like i'm
able to go to school have my own
schedule
it's just yeah and it's just like if
people hate whatever
i sit at home and make money by my
schedule
is so amazing it's night time i wake up
and i make money
i was about to say what about the
important part the money
the money yeah yeah you know i just
bought those prada shoes
you know i just got those like because
i bought like a john paul gautier sure
after yeah
yeah my favorite part is definitely like
the money ah that sounds really shitty
but that's my favorite part is
definitely
money makes the world go round right
like come on like he doesn't like nice
things like
if a man breaks my heart i go and buy a
louie bag
exactly and like it's our job like we're
just making a living like anybody else
exactly it's just another of course we
want money we want to pay our bills and
pay for things we need
it's a service that people feel about
you like
since you're doing sex work all my
friends are super supportive
my friends are like go girl yes i don't
i haven't told the guys i'm with and
yeah my family kind of kind of doesn't
and are not chilly
my close friends and family know
everyone else it's like you can find out
if you want to find out
but um yeah the important people know
and support me
has anyone like ever found you guys no
nobody's found like anybody that you
know my dad knows only because my cousin
snitched me out but i deny it until she
can show me proof of what i do
so i was like i was like okay i'm doing
only things
so i think someone that i know found me
but they went under a different name but
i'm pretty sure i know it's easy
yeah dude people do that all right it's
a lot of that too like they're hating
they're haters like they don't make
money well i'm from l.a so it's like
it's
very normal it's very much like what
everyone's kind of doing right now
my job isn't a hard sell because um or
it's not as harder as to sell to people
because um
i just mainly do dom stuff i guess it's
easy
it's not as hard of a cell because it's
like you're not like doing right because
you're not like getting naked you're not
getting like penetration you don't have
to play with yourself really
no none of that no none of that you
don't do that
i wish i had that toughness to do some
dominance
it's tough it is hard work to be a dom
it is
like it's weird all the right parts to
like whip
too much guy on a chat for an hour yeah
there's a lot to learn
and it's exhausting yeah it is
i felt like i kind of blended in very
well no one really questioned anything i
said
i think i'm gonna vote for jessica
i don't know honestly i'm just gonna
toss it up here i'm gonna go with susie
i'm kind of looking at jessica as
suspicious now
she kind of just talks about like buying
prada and stuff
sorry jessica i really thought you were
a sex worker at first
but now i'm not so sure yeah i think i'm
gonna have to vote out
mandy so i think we got everyone out but
i think i'm back to being suspicious
about
susie i'm voting someone out because i
want more money
we're going to do that we do have
another tie
and the tie is between susie
and jessica what
damn come on you guys i know you're not
better than that
all right guys look here's the deal i'm
a dumb ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
here and i put those [ __ ] boys in their
place
on cam okay i tell them to sit on the
floor
with their fingers up their butts and
cry to me that i am their goddess
so you know what if you do not know that
i do this for a living
and i just spit off the top of my head
like a psycho girl in my
dominatrix like well i don't really wear
a dominatrix outfit that much because
who loves time all right that's 30
seconds
[Music]
so i guess i'm in the spot again but uh
to prove my innocence this is pretty
much my room where i film
i got my lights right here seeing that
yeah
yeah i got a towel on the floor like you
know
um
i pretty much do a role play and cosplay
just because
that seems to be the niche and fetish
that i
unfortunately fit into um just
kind of playing into you know that
that asian fetish
i'm pretty sure it's suzy
i'm just gonna stick with my gut i think
that jessica is a sex worker
drumroll please
i think i got eliminated because my lack
of confidence and also because
the legend derek jessica answered before
me
and you couldn't have beat that answer
no way
i'm pretty proud of myself i thought i'd
be voted off the first round
if everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all
you can end the game now give a thumbs
up if you want to continue the game
or a thumbs down if you think you caught
them all and want to end the game now
do one more one more one more round one
more
one more okay what is the craziest thing
that you have seen on cam or done on cam
i'll start first like i said i'm not
good at
like the dominant crap i can't do it i
got a guy who was so
into it that he had me watch him like
and just say like just nasty stuff for
like two
hours i had a guy who
sat in a plastic bathtub with a ton of
different kind of food around him and he
wanted me to tell him
where to put the food he was like call
me a pig and he was putting the food
inside and i was like having him
smash it on himself i was dying i had
other people in my room too
that were like laughing i was like look
at this stupid
yeah i've made guys like eat dog food
before
because like people like used to be
treated like dogs
yeah dog food lit toilet bowls
um drink toilet water what do you guys
feel about like your customers like how
do you feel about them
like i have friends a lot of my
customers are my friends like
i have a snapchat um that they can pay
for and like they add me
and like some of them like i actually
legitimately enjoy talking to them yeah
they're not all
[ __ ] some of them are not no most of
them are really
most of them are really great yeah like
they're just normal people just like us
and a lot of them are funny and just
send me memes like
we're just friends are you guys in any
relationships right now
i i am but he's he's alright with it
yeah my boyfriend does not care at all
i'm not in a relationship and i don't
plan to do this for my whole life so
like i feel like once i get into a
relationship this
might be like a past tense thing to be
honest yeah oh i feel that
yeah i feel like i want to be done at 25
oh really
i want to do sex work for as long as i
possibly can like i'm in this for the
long game
it's just like my dream job like the
freedom i can't imagine going back to
working for somebody else
i'm gonna vote out anna though she just
hasn't been like
popping to me it's very very very
possible that she is
like a streamer or something like that
jessica said she thinks that when she
gets in a relationship
that she won't be doing sex work anymore
and i don't think that is a popular
take i hated
voting mandy out but she i just feel
like she didn't say as much as the other
girls
but i like her whenever i open eyes
i don't know the next person eliminated
is mandy whoa
okay bad choice
i just knew too much i was too confident
and they just wanted more money
because it couldn't be anything that i
said i think everyone
i think everyone here i think we got i
think we did
i mean give me a thumbs up if you want
to continue the game or a thumbs down if
you think you caught them all and want
to end the game now
thumbs up thumbs up if you want to
continue thumbs down if you think you
caught them
and fortunately you guys
caught them all
[Music]
who was it
did you position yourself in your room
like that so you could use
your room as a prop no honestly i still
close on depop
so this is like my setup for selling
clothes
so i was like let's just use this i
watch this show all the time
and i didn't i know you're excited
all right nice meeting y'all see you
later guys bye